please god if i ask the good lord for
one thing on this day that i come back
to the grid please tell me that the
recall situation is going well i have a
sense
that it might be because i did do one
thing over this course of the month
related to all this i did have one
dinner for larry elder because there was
a fundraising thing that i felt it was
important that i was at to help help him
make some connections um and everyone
knew i was off the grid so i didn't hear
anything but i i got a sense this was
about halfway through the month that
there was some momentum there please god
adam even if you want to lie to me a
little bit give me some hope here we got
14 days like please the little momentum
come on
well
i think larry does have some momentum
because
the la times is launching attack pieces
against him and so is cnn it's on this
that's as good as it gets that all you
need is the attack pieces that means
it's going well perfect right uh
a headline out of the l.a times that
you'll particularly enjoy was that larry
elder
is the new face of white supremacy
and i i oftentimes think of you
and i cite you a lot because your story
of going from the left to the right yeah
and saying
it seems impossible that everyone who
disagrees with us is racist
it seems improbable statistically
because they're we're talking about
economic policy
except for everyone i'm arguing with is
racist if i'm on on the left and so
here's the thing um uh they are so
out of
ideas on the left and can do nothing to
larry elder's policies they can't attack
his policies
they literally just have sexism and
racism those are the two things so
they're focusing um cnn with jim acosta
ran a piece
that was so laughable it was insane they
pulled a clip of larry elder's radio
show from four years ago where he made
an innocuous joke about uh women
marching in the in the million women
march and the gist of the joke was
trump
has motivated more fat women to get off
the sofa
in march than michelle obama did with
her health initiative it's a good joke
and it's a tr it's true
and then jim acosta called it disgusting
which by the way makes him makes him
he's such a clown he's such a [ __ ] but
okay i and by the way he's a liar he
doesn't think that's disgusting but the
point is cnn has entered the fray that's
um that is great so it's getting so it's
finally getting national attention
that's that's what i was saying right
before i went off the grid that one of
the types of fake news is that the media
just ignores things it's not just they
lie about everything it's that they
ignore certain things so if cnn's
hitting this right now
that is spectacular
yes they are now
one has to say which i always find it's
something i i talk to drive dr drew
about privately all the time which is
i do not get the los angeles times
here's an interesting statistic
um because i went and looked it up
california
always looks at itself as sort of the
vanguard for all progressive movements
like as california goes so follows the
nation and the world you know we set
we're the leader in gay marriage and
we're the leader of social justice like
we're the leader
um
we've had governors for over 150 years
we've never had a black governor
never so california
has never had a black governor we've had
governors since 18 since 1849
we've never had a black governor
and the la times who's on the vanguard
of diversity
is going to attack the first potential
black governor of california so what are
the rules
friends on the left are the rules we
want black people in positions of power
because i don't think that's the rule
just be clear we want black people who
agree with us in power and if not you're
candace owens or larry elder you're not
even black we like which is the
minorities who bow forever that's what
it is we don't like gays we like gays
who bow forever we like black people who
bow forever we like women who bow
forever look it sounds to me i know i've
been out of it for a little while sounds
to me like the la times has gone full
white supremacist
i don't but my whole point is how do you
do this with a straight face that's my
whole point and
all you have
is
um anyone who wants to run and and all
larry elder talks about is school choice
and regulation and border security and
all that kind of stuff and all they talk
about is
racism
and by the way if you want to know how
brazen they are
they're doing with a black male i mean i
know you know that but i mean it's like
they're so committed to their calls of
racism for anyone who opposes them that
they will do it for a guy who was born
in south central and attended crenshaw
high
that's how committed they are to to
calling everyone a racist and by the way
on september 14th the key thing is you
just have to vote yes or no on the
recall that's the beautiful thing so who
in their right mind is going to vote
that day and be like yes everything's
great even if you're a complete
progressive nut bag who in their right
mind would go to the polling place that
day and be like yes we want more of
gavin newsom we want more homelessness
we want more drugs on the street we want
less policing all of those things like
that's why i think there's some hope
here because what was it something like
1.7 million people hand signed the
recall because you had to do it hand
sign right you couldn't do it online so
those people are going to be
incentivized those people are going to
be excited to get out there on the 14th
how many of newsome's people are going
to be really excited unless you can
trick them into thinking that the black
man is a white supremacist
wait so are there any numbers are there
any numbers like polling numbers or
anything or you just the sense is that
we're in good shape here i think it's
sort of within the
margins of error i think uh you know
later it's amazing that's amazing
yeah 46.3 versus 50.6
i don't
i don't know how how old this
uh survey is i'm guessing it's fairly
current if your people
dug it up but it's it's it's there we're
within a few ticks and um who the heck
knows
so um so that's good news i'm telling
you man i'm going to devote the next two
weeks of my life to making this thing
happen maybe i'm crazy but you and i
stayed you know knowles shapiro the rest
of those guys they fled but what if
corolla and ruben lead the tr and dr
drew you know lead the charge to save
this freaking thing and then instead of
oh the country goes as california goes
it's the country gets saved because we
save california i'm not kidding i'm
devoting the next two weeks of my life
to this no matter i will do i just i
actually just texted i did pick up my
phone this morning to text and i texted
larry i said anything you need anything
i'm there so let's see yeah well
look um
again
you cannot do worse than gavin newsom so
this is different than gavin newsom and
uh i said to somebody once who said uh
this is months ago before larry got into
the fray i said uh who would you like
over gavin newsom and i said one of
those plastic owls that people put up on
their sign at the restaurant at the
beach so the seagulls don't crap on it
yeah that would be fine
the owl wouldn't be destructive
you just just be just be there by the
way all right wait one quick thing on
this which is um you know i've seen
these ads on youtube as i was watching
just old basketball games where this guy
do you know who this guy is this reed
hastings guy he's the ceo of netflix and
he's been basically gavin newsom's uh
piggy bank for this thing so he runs
these crazy anti-larry elder ads and
it's yeah implying he's a white
supremacist and he's an anti-vaxxer and
in one of the ads they basically are
like voting for gavin newsom is a life
or death decision i'm slightly
paralyzing but that's basically what it
says the implication that larry is going
to kill your children and gavin newsom
who you're telling me kovit's not going
so well he's been in charge this whole
time he's obviously going to save your
children these people the lies man
these are not good people if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell